kölns care im zentralpolen in dem
beschaulichen städtchen kommt es am 12
september 1939 zu einem tragischen
vorfall die wehrmacht verübt an der
polnischen zivilbevölkerung ein massaker
vor ort ist eine berühmte augenzeugen
die regisseurin leni riefenstahl ein
internationales aushängeschild des
dritten reiches der sonder film trupp
riefenstahl soll im auftrag adolf
hitlers den feldzug in polen und die
heldentaten der wehrmacht für die
nachwelt auf film verewigen
sie hatte alle möglichen vollmachten
sie wurde auch technisch perfekt
ausgestattet sie bekam zwei autos ein
motorrad mit beiwagen eine schutztruppe
kurz sie hatte grosse freiheiten weil
adolf hitler und joseph goebbels davon
überzeugt waren dass dank der begabung
von leni riefenstahl ein wunderbarer
monumentaler film über den sieg in polen
entstehen wird seit riefenstahl in ihrem
film triumph des willens über den
reichsparteitag 1934 den führerkult
perfekt in szene gesetzt hat ist sie
hitlers lieblings regisseuren
das propagandawerk verherrlicht die ns
volksgemeinschaft in einem
massenspektakel
auch ihr olympia film mit dem
ausgeprägten körperkult liegt ganz auf
der linie der rassistischen ns ideologie
zugleich ist auch dieser film eine
verneigung vor dem führerstaat in konz
kia erwartet die regisseurin am 12
september bilder von heroischen soldaten
gewaltigen schlachtszenen und glänzenden
siegesfeier
doch die realität des krieges sieht
anders aus jüdische zivilisten werden an
diesem tag von den deutschen
zusammengetrieben und gezwungen auf
einem kirchenvorplatz gräber für
gefallener wehrmachtsoldaten auszuheben
riefenstahl wird zeugin wie die
deutschen soldaten die juden mit
brutalen schlägen zum graben antreiben
schneller endlich lang die juden
ehrliche arbeit kennen die regisseurin
ist entsetzt und protestiert hört auf
damit das ist eines deutschen soldaten
nicht würdig so schildert sie es in
ihren memoiren eine darstellung die
heute umstritten ist
[Musik]
man muss sich fragen inwieweit man ihr
glauben darf
denn es gibt keine parallel quellen dazu
die ihre version bestätigen würden
leni riefenstahl hat auch in ihren
interviews oft die in wahrheit erzählt
immer wieder finden sich widersprüche in
ihren aussagen nehmen die ereignisse an
diesem tag eine fatale wende ein soldat
gibt einen schuss ab unter den
gefangenen bricht panik aus
sie fliehen und werden von den deutschen
niedergeschossen
riefenstahl wird am 12 september
augenzeugen wie deutsche soldaten der
zehnten armee amok laufen über 20
unschuldige jüdische zivilisten bezahlen
an diesem tag die skis mut der truppe
mit dem leben
unmittelbar nach dem massaker von konz
kia verlässt riefenstahl die front sie
kehrt nie wieder auf einen
kriegsschauplatz zurück wie sie selbst
später betont
man kann sagen dass leni riefenstahl
nach den ereignissen von konz kia ihren
auftrag nicht erfüllt hat nämlich den
großen film zu drehen
sie zog sich zurück aber ihre
mitarbeiter drehten diesen film weiter
und deren arbeit wurde dann zur
grundlage des dokumentarfilms dem wir
unter dem titel feldzug in polen kennen
und der vom sieg der wehrmacht über
polen handelt aber leni riefenstahl hat
ihren namen für diesen film nicht mehr
hergegeben
bei seinem erscheinen 1940 wird der von
riefenstahls kameraleuten unterstützte
propagandafilm von der ns führung als
staatspolitisch wertvoll und volks
bildend eingeschätzt während die
gleichgeschaltete presse die
rekordbesucherzahlen in den kinos des
reiches feiert
vom riefen stolz handschrift ist in
diesem film allerdings nichts mehr zu
spüren
riefenstahl scheint sich rasch von den
schrecken in konz kia erholt zu haben
im oktober 1939 nimmt sie an der
siegesfeier in warschau auf einer
tribüne teil im dritten reich dreht sie
weiter filme auf staatskosten von der ns
diktatur wird sie sich auch nach dem
krieg nicht eindeutig distanzieren